this morning a u.s navy nuclear engineer
is accused of trying to sell
confidential information
to a foreign country authorities say the
suspect's contact person was not a
foreign agent however but an fbi agent
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge is at the pentagon
for us catherine good morning to you
every detail of this story is out of a
bad movie but sounds like a pretty good
piece of work from law enforcement good
morning
well tony this is an extraordinary
national security case that combines
allegations of spying nuclear submarine
secrets and a peanut butter sandwich
according to court documents in april
last year navy nuclear engineer jonathan
toby of annapolis maryland sent
documents to an unnamed foreign
government to sell sensitive information
according to the criminal complaint the
package was later obtained by the fbi
which began a months-long surveillance
operation in which an undercover agent
paid toby thousands in cryptocurrency in
exchange for information about the us's
virginia-class nuclear-powered attack
submarines toby was arrested saturday in
west virginia along with his school
teacher wife diana who prosecutors say
was acting as a lookout after he
allegedly went to a secret location
known in the spy world as a dead drop
and left a memory card with restricted
data wrapped in plastic and placed
between two slices of bread on half of a
peanut butter sandwich the half sandwich
was housed inside of a plastic bag so
far there's been no public comment from
the couple who are due in court tomorrow
gail
never thought that a peanut butter
sandwich would be considered ominous
i know that's a wild story thank you
catherine you're welcome we